Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier!
And welcome back to Prey...
Now we just got done with fixing up the LOOKING GLASS.
Now we need to go back to my office-
"MY OFFICE!" And uh...finish the rest of the message that was delivered to me.
But wasn't able to be completed adub-
Mark: OW!
suit feedback: life signs critical
OKAY!
I DIDN'T MEAN TO DO THAT!
OW! (Again)
YOU SONOFA BITCH
I'M GONNA LOAD!
Fuck!!
You!!
I didn't know THAT was gonna happen
That was a way to start an episode, eh.
Alright, but either way we gotta get back to myyy...
Home base which might mean...
Alright, lemme do something here.
I've never done this before
I wanna kinda try this.
Oh YEAH I MEANT TO GO THROUGH THE WINDOW THERE.
That's definitely the thing that I wanted to do.
HYEP!
HWO WHOAH WHOAH
What was that?
HOP
Can I climb that?
I know I could just.....whoah
Who's up there?
Euh, what is up there?
Hang on I gotta see this
Somethings up there.... whooh okay
Yah okay gonna pretend like that didn't just happen
Huh
Wha-? WUT
You didn't look outside your own goddamn door to see if there was any wrong over there
You just assumed that everything was hunky-dokie
and everything was just happy and smiles out there
and as soon as you look out, "oh no! mimics!"
Thank you for that
oh, I'm gonna be feeling better as soon as you get out of my face
yeah, shut up, shut up, shut up, shut up
I don't have time for you, I love you, thank you
MWAH kisses
oh
OHH
HI!
Well that where I just was.
Maybe there was some important information to be over there
but noo- oh...hi
OH HI!
WHAT THE FUCK!
How did I miss you!!
Not what I wanted not what I wanted!
I wanted to glue you good, glue you good-euh uh okay.
Just gonna BASH you-
BAM!
Guh- WHOA bye okay, alright see ya.
Uh, bam?
Okay I guess he's dead then!
Oooh! Spare parts!
I'll take that.
Hupty woopty!
Alright someone's over here.
And I'm about to find out who.
I got plenty of GLOO-oooh.
HEY!
What the fuck- hi. Fuck you!
Can you not do that?
Uh-oh.
That ain't good--AIYAIYAIYAIYAIYA!
I know I'm--I know I've gotta healy do over here somewhere.
I'm gonna--WHOA!
You god damn asshole!
With your fucking bullshit--AH-HA-HOW!
GODDAMNIT
Okay I think the lesson to be learned there is don't take those guys head-on.
Or at least only get one good whap on them and then hope for the best later.
Because that did not go well for me.
Alright.
I'm just gonna...
Oh yeah, get him up here so I can actually beat the shit outta you.
Na nananananana-OW-nanana,
Okay give him one gooood WHOMPUS!
And then the rest of him--BAM BABY!
Whoa where'd ya go?
Where'd ya go baby?
Hah?
Where'd you run off to you coward?
Now that I know where the little thing is--oh hi.
You're right there, aren't ya?
Oh ho! Ho ho! Big bang candy! No good luck for you.
Sneak attack!
Uh-ho!
WHAH!
Ah ha, missed me.
Missed me baby.
Maybe if I could re-engage stealth over and over again I'd be able to get a little bit of a bonus there.
Bet I could.
Ohh...SNICK SNACK! THE PATTY WHACK!
WHOA
Give a dog a bone.
SHA BUSHKI!
Whoa, where ya going?
Alright-y then.
Man they run qu-ick--oh I seem him back there.
Oh, I see you.
AH! God they do that quick attack!
What can you do against that?
You can't do anything!
There's literally nothing you could do against that.
Oooh, hello.
No password found but I can hack it.
I don't know what the good with this would do but I'm gonna go for it.
Yalalalal
Shupidu woopidy woodpidy woodpidy woopidy--AND "C".
Yay! I'm a masterful hacker.
Hello.
*reading screen*
Okay.
I already broke in there, sorry about that!
"Glue adhesion"...
Uhhhh....."vitreophobic"...
Okay, well that's not very useful to me, but there's another guy in here somewhere.
Oh.
Okay then.
Ha boshki, HA BUSHKI!
Alrighty then.
I'm just gonna carry on as if nothing's bad.
Take these...
Nothing there...
Ah, dammnit, I'm full up again.
"Cooking with cauliflower"?
I love cauliflower, but this isn't the time for that.
Alright, I need to take care of this guy then carry on with my life.
Oh no you don't. No, I'm not up here. No no no no no no.
You don't know nothing about me!
And I don't know nothing about you. I'm just hunting for-NEUROMODS!
GODDAMNIT!
Dooon't even think about it.
NOOOO!
Alright.
I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna get healed.
And then I'm gonna move on, because I am not doing to well there.
HEY MISTER OPERATOR PLEASE HEAL MY WOUNDS
Yeah, seems pretty life-threatening considering I'm about to die.
I'm not gonna do that.
Okay, here we go.
I know there's a way back down
but I'm just gonna try to get the drop on this guy so I don't have to deal with them
bishing my head in.
No, I don't know what bishing my head in means so everybody shoosh.
HULLO!
Ah good, a banana peel, or a lemon peel, or something equally useless.
Thank you for that. Hello.
*reading screen*
*loud noise*
Alrighty then...
*reading screen*
YA MEAN LIKE ME AND BEING AN IDIOT?
Okay, well that's good to know.
*reading screen*
O-kay.
Alrighty then.
IS THIS THE ONE?
SIX, SIX--ahw shit.
SIX THREE EIGHT ONE.
Goody goody gum drops! I don't know what's going on in here.
Oooooh, okay.
AH HI
Didn't mean that! Jorgen!
Jorgen!
Jorgen don't do it!
Jorgen you have so much to die for!
JORGEN NO
Okay, where'd ya go?
Ho-oooooh you died.
Oooh. I'm officially out of-
Why did he resent me?
And also, do I want an asteroid fragment? That seems moderately important.
I'LL JUST DRINK THIS THEN
GLUGIDY GLUG GLUG
Uhg--take that I guess.
Alright, do you--please tell me you have a neuromod somewhere in here.
That seems incredibly useful.
Alright.
Doctors Cach-ah wha-?
HOW DID I HURT MYSELF?
UUHAA!
Get outta here!
Hiyeah!
Okay.
*reading screen*
Huh. Igwe.
Oh, I'm sorry that I'm SO high maintenance!
Yaaaas!
That's what I was looking for. That's what I was looking for!
Can I...
Do I--okay.
So Dr. Thorstein must have a code here somewhere.
Uuh...Nope.
Hm. Where oh where. OH where oh where would Dr. Thorstein--
Ah! I see something up there.
I'M GONNA GO UP THERE--WITH A STAIRCASE OF GLOOPY GOOP.
That's not--almost there. Getting it.
Kind of...I'm gonna accept that because I've got no alternatives.
Ha--AAAH!
Ah frick a dick.
Hey hi. How's it going there?
Where did--where did you come from?
Ah goddamnit.
No I don't think so. Not today.
Woh.
Alright I'm gonna try this again.
Try this one more time.
I know--I think I can get up there. I think I...
Whoa...
Dammnit.
DAMMNIT
What if I did this.
Oh maybe I don't even need that. Maybe I just--
yeah, that seems--AAH HA!
Okay fine. Maybe not that, but maybe if I go up here.
One more try at that one. Let me crack that again.
Ah yes! Ah hello. Are you a code?
No, you're a frayed wire and spare parts.
I though you mighta been a code up here!
Decided to dick me over.
Fine I get it.
Maybe I deserve a good dicking.
At least I got my GLOO gun to keep me comfortable at night.
So, frick you!
Alright, so what else've we got here?
Med kit!
Nothing else there. Nothing else there.
Okay, so I don't see a code here.
Euuuhh...
Aahh..
Okay I can't find it right now so maybe I'll find it if I keep going forward
and then I can cycle back to it.
I mean, I can't believe that Dr. Thorstein was also a mimic.
Like there must be something going with those Neuromods. There has to be.
Hello?
HII, I'M GONNA CARRY ON OKAY? ALRIGHT YOU ALL HAVE A GOOD DAY.
GOODBYE SEE YA IN THE NEXT--NEVER!
FUUACK YOUUU
Alright I'm gonna go carry back and I'm gonna go see this uh looking glass tuteriul thinga mabobber
message from myself.
But unfortunately I think the glass might be a little bit borked.
Unless ~magically~ it repaired itself in the-the transitional loading screens of magic
and awesomeness because this universe is filled with self-repairing materials
which would be awfully niiice.
But then again, maybe not and that's just a fever dream of me.
Morgan. The totally human, not mimic Yu.
HEEY!
Where did you come from?
NOOOO!
HO MY GOD!
AAII!
Turret turret turret turret--WHY ARE YOU HERE?
NO!
Get away from my goddamn turret.
No! No! BAM.
HEEY!
You sack a shit!
Ho-oly crap, that guy was tough!
Oh my god, okay I'll be right back!
Frick a dick, I don't have enough ammo for all of this.
You assholes are gonna be the death of me that is for damn sure.
Oh my god I got so much shit.
Alright I'm just gonna transfer all that.
But man! I need more ammo and I need it NOW.
So if I can't make more Neuromods soon, I'm just gonna spend what I got and see if I can get something that'll .
allow me to carry more material because this is getting ridiculous
I just need it.
I've got THREE.
So I get some MUSCLE on my bad boy limbs then maybe I should be able to do something
EXTRA INVENTORY space!
Yaaas! How much more?
How much more we talking here? Because there's three potentials there. I wanna see this.
YES!
That looks like marginally more!
Oh, I see. It does another row and a column.
Ah, so it get incrementally larger as time goes on.
But that's already gonna be a HUGE help for me.
'cuz I gotta go back and I gotta get all the goop.
And then I'm gonna take care of these sons a bitches.
I'm gonna carry this guy.
I'ma bring him over here. I'm gonna show these guys WHAT FOR and to stop freaking duplicating on me.
Because if they can stop that, that'd be great...
I don't know where you guys went.
Ready to scan, but where the hell did they go?
I got a mysterious explosive canister that for some reason this lovely facility
full of civilians carries around at RANDOM JUNCTURES IN THE HALLWAY!
Alright then, I'm just gonna trust that this is all hunky doodle and I'm gonna get the fudge outta here.
I'm gonna leave that guy there though.
'Cuz I don't trust that AT ALL.
NOT AT ALL.
Not even the littlest bit.
Okay.
Alright.
Aw, it's still a little, but oddly enough not as damaged as it once was were.
So I'm gonna turn that on again and I'm gonna resume this.
Shupity woopdy!
Hello? I'm ready!
OOH! It fixed itself!
OH the future is magic!
Okay.
UUMM..
Well, I mean you were right about one thing.
I didn't like it but, 5150, I do have that code.
Well January what do you have to say about--oh hi--OOH!
Hi January.
You're special.
Over here? I'm looking right at you.
Cool.
Okay.
Okay!
Alright.
Okay. Uuh..
Okay!
Alright then!
Thank you January!
Really--whoa, thank you for that. I'll take that key card you just SHAT out onto my desk.
Ho.
Thank you!
Just one?
J-just one?
NO
OOOH--KAY
Oh.
So they WERE aliens. Hey come back here comeback here!
Why would Alex fail to release me?
That seems ridiculous.
Okay though.
I'm just gonna trust like you know what you're talking about.
Ooh. I think I've already been there brah.
I think I've already WELL been there.
Okay, so now...I can at least get rid of...
Something... Ah I just don't know what to get rid of anymore!
I don't even know if I need to get rid of this thing!
I've got another weapon mod. UUHRAR!
Alright I'm gonna keep this for now because I did get more inventory space which is gonna be good.
And I can get more of that later. I'm sure I'm gonna make a lot more.
Okay, BUT, for now I do have materials and I need to start making more bullets.
Crap that please, thank you!
'Cuz I've got a lot of...I've got a lot of synthetic material...
And...I've got a lot of...
I've got a lot of DNA, oddly enough, which means I should be able to make more Neuromods soon.
'Cuz that makes sense that they're made out of ALIENS and ALIEN PARTS.
The responsibility of everything we've got going on here.
So, anyway! That's everything that seems to be in here.
I see--ooh.
OOOH THAT WAS JUST THERE?
Well that wasn't obvious AT ALL!
WELL THIS WAS JUST HERE?
WELL SHIT DUDE
Well fucking hell!
Holy shit shonkers.
What in the hell? Recycling Shielding *reading description*.
Okay!
I guess that's good!
I don't know why I got that but I guess that's good!
Okay.
Well, I've already upgraded this one so it's only really a cosmetic change isn't it?
Well, it is pretty though so...I'm gonna give it that.
I'll recycle the other one just because...I don't know.
Aw, but I already spent a weapon upgrade on it!
Aw!
It GOLD?
Superior electronic gun that delivers the ultimate shoot expeeerience!
Aww... But y'know to be honest, I already-- I already did upgrade the other one...
I did it!
It SAYS it's better, but to be honest it doesn't look like it's any better.
It honestly don't.
So, you know what?
I'm sorry margrave. Hey!
I know you look pretty! I know you're great!
And whatnot! And whatever! But...
Ol' reliable was here first!
Ol' reliable has been with me since the beginning! I found Or' lalalaraiable.
So I'm sorry.
You're gonna get recycled.
And I know you guys probably aren't too happy about
but I STAND BY THE GUNS THAT STAND BY ME.
And just because I didn't find you doesn't mean I owe you shit!
GET IN THERE! And you be recycled!
Thank you.
You poofed out into these two pieces of bullshit.
And know I got my old sweetie here.
And you know what, just to solidify, just to rub some salt in the wound,
I'm gonna upgrade this bad boy here.
Oh hey.
Oh--oh, ammo capacity? Nah, don't need that.
Recoil? Oh hell yeah. Oh we're gonna want some of that.
I mean we're gonna want less of that, which is exactly what we're gonna get when we do THAT!
So, let's keep going on.
Alright. Let's move on!
Now that I've done what I can here to do which is be a freaking badass.
So now...what do I need to do? I need to go on the elevator I think.
"Deep storage, locate crew member"...
That's right. I needed to get to Devries.
And Devries 7324, he's in the arboretum, which is in the elevator which I also need to go to.
"Get Bellamy's room key from his body" and he's in Psychotronics...
Which means I need to go from the lobby to Psychotronics. Okay.
And I don't know what G.U.T.S. is.
That seems bad. But I do need to go to the Arboretum, so I'm gonna go there first
and then I'll go to Bellamy to retrieve--oh they're down there.
OH, I'm gonna get the turret!
I'm 100% gonna get the turret! I'm not taking on three of those guys by my lonesome.
Like holy shit, are they out of their minds?
NO WAY!
NO WAY in hell!
No way in fresh fronking hell!
Okay, so I guess they must've already taken out the turret down there.
Oh man this guy is crying. He is so ready to kill.
That's what that sound is--GOD DAMNIT! WHAT THE FUCKING--WHAT??
How is that even fair?
How is that even faaair?
That is ludicrous. Oh and this gun's back! You get the fudge outta my face!
Don't you laugh at me! You get recycle you bitch!
Alright so I got that.
Alright I'm gonna go off on my way.
I'm going to...I don't know. Maybe throw and EMP charge or something.
I have no idea. I guess I just need to be a little more sneaky about this because those assholes...
Man they mean business!
I just didn't even get a chance to set this up.
So what I gotta do is I gotta get down to the first floor and set it up immediately at like the top of the stairs or something.
Because these guys
They know what the fudge is up.
And what the fudge is up is my death if they GET CLOSER TO ME! NOOO!
HOW!
My god! How do you even--how do you even--how do you even do that!
How do you do that!
No! No! No! No! Oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god! Oh my GOD!
Oh my god oh my god oh my god! BAP!
Oh my god, they hurt! What they fuck?
Oh my god oh my god oh my god!
Geezums, those guys are assholes!
Oh there's still one more down there.
Those guys are GIANT DOUCHES!
Those guys are douches of the HIIIIGHEST  CALIBER!
Anyway...
Geezums...Oh I didn't--it didn't get destroyed, it just fell down here.
See if I can--oh it's broken, never mind. It's broken.
Okay, sure adjust your attitude there bitch.
No no no, you're gonna get blasted SO HARD!
HO HO HO! HO HO TO BITS YOU SAY!
Oh to shreds you say.
I need to double upgrade my freaking shawshgun.
God damn.
These sons a DICKS.
OH.
And I'm gonna upgrade my piawstal.
See if I can upgrade that.
Range?
Oh yeah, oh yeah! Give me that shit.
I am loyal to the weapons with what doth are loyal to me!
Okay, I don't think there's another one around here.
Oddly enough I don't think so.
So I think I'm okay.
Wait a minute...nah, nothing.
Okay, so I'm gonna go to the main lift.
And I'm gonna go...You know what?
Maybe I should go back.
Maybe I--maybe I--maybe I should go back. 5150. There is that safe and that seems pretty secretive
so I"m gonna go back. So I'll be right back.
Because I'm about to run all the way back. You'll only see me if something horrible happens on the way to there.
But I'll be right back.
Okay I made it. Alright. 5150.
I probably could've guessed that from that because now it seems obvious., but I know it now, so.
5150.
Yay!
Ooh yay! Oooh yay! What's the Potentializer?
"Increases maximum psi pool by 50"?
I don't have any scope chip sets, so.
What about that then?
I guess I have that now.
So that I've been worth it. If that's gonna be really good in the future, then at least I have that for now.
So anyway I'm gonna make my way back so see you in a bit.
Whoa...okay.
Well, debris was flying out of that hole in space at an extremely fast clip
but I'm going carry on to the main lift and hopefully I'm gonna be able to take that up to the Arboretum.
Which should prove to difficult to do. I THINK anyway.
I'm gonna call that, I'm gonna go to the Arboretum.
God dammit a malfunction?
Why?
What do I need to do?
Hello?
How?
Is it 'cuz you're a robot?
Okay.
Yeah please do because I don't think I can progress any more if you don't fi--ooh.
That's okay I needed to go there anyway!
I kinda want to know what's going on in the Psychotronics lab...
Okay.
Thank's for having that conversation on loud speaker.
That's really nice I-I think anyway.
I'm gonna release this door?
Okay.
Monthly what? *reading note*
Oh that's cheerful.
Alright.
*reading screen*
Well, I know for a fact Yuri Kimura is now dead,
but that's not my main point that I was trying to make
I was trying to make.. the point that..
ah, I can't hack that I don't have enough hacking
need more hacking, somehow.
I gotta get more neuromods
Like, initially neuromods were just raining from the ceiling, so
suddenly they just stopped--
*funny voice, reads sign* "You're entering a maximum security area"
That is so deadspace.
Okay, thanks December!
Why does everyone have code names?!
I mean you're not people, I guess
I'm sorry if that's rude of me to say
Also, I have five neuromods?
When did I get five neuromods?
Well, that's frickdickin' awesome, okay,
so what am I gonna do with these neuromods then?
I could get more hacking,
which would actually allow me to be able to hack some good stuff
or I could get even more...
*low voice* I could get even more inventory space, which I always love...
*normal voice* Or I could get more hacking
which seems INFINITELY more useful, so I'm gonna do that.
YAY! I can hack stuff now.
And then once I'm able to craft neuromods
it won't be a problem at all, I think, anyway..
All right, but I think that's the only thing in here
so CARRY ON, my wayward son..
But that is so Deadspace, right?
That reminds me of everything about Deadspace,
even down to this, like, informational panels here.
I mean, I'm not saying it's copying Deadspace in the way,
I'm saying in a very pleasant way, it reminds me of Deadspace.
And I am totally cool with that, because that is flippin' awesome.
Man...
Oh...
I wish it was MORE horror right now,
I wish I was like, terrified outta my mind--
I mean,  this game has had some good jumpscares but in the end it's still
a bit more action than it is
like, uh
non-action.
Where are you?
OHH, YOU'RE RIGH- YYYYOOOU'R- R
R- RAH!
HO!
GET GOOED!
No no no, get gooed get gooed
get gooed get gooed get gooed
Bam!
Oh goddammit!
POOOOOWW!!!
Ohhh, got ya!
Holy jeezums, okay.
Well that was only shh-sheer luck that I did that
also, I need to repair my goddamn suit
I totally forgot about that.
I've had these repair kits and I just never use 'em
Maybe I should hold off just because there MIGHT be a repair operator
around here somewhere.
because that is exteme-a-ly useful.
And I don't want to waste 'em
just in case I need 'em in an extreme emergency.
But,
then again, what's the point of holding onto 'em if I'm never gonna use 'em, right?
Yeah, whatever, I'll-
WOOOAH-AA-III I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS
Maybe I shouldn't be holding it in the palm of my hand?
*reading screen*
Oooookay
That seems useful.
Also, you say
any PERSON
so I'm assuming that there are gonna be psychotronic people here.
Also, why did this guy die with a box in his ass?
Seems like a precarious situation to be caught dead in.
Unlock? Okay, here we go.
Travel? Okay, here we go.
YAY! I'm going to psychotronics
which is something to do with psychic ability
for some reason.
And it's the reason...
what was his name, Jeremy Young?
It's the reason why his head exploded
because he was...
Wait, typhon ecology in 1959
WHAT was that?
Wait, WHAT did you just say?
I didn't read that notification!